the Sun is up the dawn is due I have
been prepared to be a the morning
statement [ __ ]
anyway mm-hmm good morning everybody
today we have a very special treat on
today's mukbang food review oh my god
now when I think about this food I'm
thinking about for some reason Church
hunger doctor hunger MPO is Korean
school because every morning before I
went to Korean school and I learned how
to speak Korean ki KI sheep I'd known
the DI sheep
I hate doughnuts today we will be
reviewing and eating LA's top doughnut
places or my personal favorite top
doughnut places Sun doughnuts are
amazing their pride their pillowy
they're delicious and I'm pretty sure
there are a lot of other donut places
that you guys might like leave those in
the comment below but when you come to
LA I want you to try the places that I
like so everybody let's get it started
let's get a munching let's get a
doughnut eaten first up to bat is Astros
doughnuts and bed as the yaksa gonna
make cake pay yeah if you have good
doughnuts
very good sweet delicious doughnuts but
the thing that I liked from Astros the
most is the doughnut burgers yes my
friends I'll cut them up donut
[ __ ] burgers
we're not talking about Krispy Kreme
sweet doughnuts either I'm talking about
a savory [ __ ] fried donut here
we have my friends my favorite
concoction we have a savory donut on the
top and the bottom we got ourselves some
delicious crispy bacon we got ourselves
a delicious crispy piece of fried
chicken
pickles on the side my friends blue
cheese and house
georgina couching the child Gina
now I am a pacifist under God's request
when I first heard about this place in
there doing a savory doughnut burgers I
kind of thought like uh it might be a
bit much but the savory doughnut is
different from the sweet doughnut like I
said before is that it's not very
overpowering however let me let me just
uh I don't want to explain my [ __ ] I
just want to bite into this way to talk
about it let's take these pickles first
I'm saying cuz you need that crispity
crunchity deliciousness pickles are a
vegetable in certain parts of the world
ooh maka oh look oh no come on now come
on now come on now come on now there it
is a lot of pickles to me cuz I'm trying
to be healthy that's what's up that's
what's up hold on chicken seasoned
perfectly
crunchy outer crust on that chicken son
I'm talking about that sweet delicious
fried bread that salty vinegary pickle
ooh and now with the second bite I'm
gonna take that blue cheese put it on it
like so now I'm saying
take that hot sauce because my G hot
sauce is the truth drizzle it like so if
you ain't getting the food boner right
now you watch an amputee I mean yo dude
don't work then you're gonna add that
creaminess but all this stuff and you're
gonna get that perfect bite i'ma move
away from this real quick cuz I'm about
to get this fat pickle right here no I'm
saying you feel me on this real quick
cousin you feel me on this real quick
cousin
oh yeah I'm watching my face move my
hands not bring no damn napkins
you know when you looked at this you
guys are thinking okay it's a little
small
why the [ __ ] would I get this but it's
stack and remember it's sandwich with
fried bread so I'm pretty sure after you
eat one you're not gonna want to eat
another you know unless you're like you
really really like heavy things but when
it comes to this I usually just get one
and that's it mmm at least be pretty
happy I mean please type of foods - I
don't think this food is about balance
this food is about indulgence meaning
that everything bad in this world before
your body is in this piece of food but
you're not gonna really give a [ __ ]
which is why it comes in a smaller
package is why I enjoyed this very much
I'm not gonna want this to be like this
huge burger it'll be too much I'm not
gonna want to finish it more pickles no
pickles
my blue cheese small blue cheese
Wow how soft this is like that hot wings
hot sauce come on like buttery and tangy
it's like eating a bomb-ass hot wings
Oh mm-hmm mr. bacon
you ain't gotta leave me oh I'll be
healthier I'll leave that last blue
cheese out but we're gonna leave your
hot sauce though food makes me happy oh
I'm tasting some spice here what is that
I think that was one of the pickling
spices delicious when you really enjoy
what you're eating this last bite is
always the one that you cherish the most
because you don't want it to go but it
has to it has to if you love something
you have to let it go specifically in
your mouth and out your ass
and to you my first doughnut I beg you I
do who thought about putting a doughnut
fried chicken and bacon together you you
deserve a [ __ ] easy [ __ ]
maybe not for me my hands are a little
rough next up we have a couple doughnuts
from this place in DTLA called birdies
now I've actually never had birdies
before so this is gonna be a legitimate
review where we get to taste and try it
together I get to explain all the
flavors in my mouth now birdies
interestingly enough is actually known
for their chicken I believe they're
known for their chicken first when what
people have told me they're fried
chicken so obviously I had astros and I
had their chicken donut sandwich thing
that was going on there but I had to
make a choice which ones that I want to
eat from first so I had the chicken
donut sandwich from Astros I will try it
there next time maybe I'll do it in
another video but today we're just gonna
eat their artists and donuts so first up
let's pop open this [ __ ]
damn this is Bob what the [ __ ] is is
this is there
pistachio what what is this whoa
so this right your cousin is there lemon
Tom pistachio bippity oh the cool thing
that people are doing with Donuts is
that they're going beyond just that
regular diner coffee doughnut that you
see on the TVs now people are getting
creative they're getting exciting
they're mixing these flavors these herbs
these spices these sweets these textures
deep data uh-huh
now you asked me typically what is a
doughnut a doughnut is a fried piece of
dough I guess you would say I think like
the main ingredients are eggs flour
baking powder or baking soda or some
[ __ ] like that and it's deep-fried
typically from what I've seen ice and
other people baking and [ __ ] like that
I don't believe in that mess I like the
deep fine unless this is baked who
[ __ ] knows let's try it out look how
pretty this is
sometimes when shits so pretty you ain't
try to eat it but I wasn't here before
mm-hmm mm-hmm they doing it right here
let me explain to you what's going on
him
sweet cream on top that lemon and thyme
really shines through lemon and thyme
too is a bomb-ass combination you
wouldn't really think that you will put
that into a sweet dessert but it really
works it's like mmm listen I love
Cambodian doughnut shops but sometimes I
don't want to [ __ ] Cambodia and donut
I want a white person silver link
doughnut just right here cousin did I
don't say it good for you mouthing what
hmm
oh yeah I can't stop eating this oh I
think I little the first time I ever had
a doughnut or why I can remember it was
that church every Sunday I just think
I'm gonna keel over and how to speak
Korean
right crane anyone has Church donuts and
coffee well you never had doughnuts like
this so I actually got sick of eating
donuts at a certain point because this
is the same [ __ ] over and over you know
the same glazed doughnut it's the same
maple bars [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
I want something fancy mmm I'm gonna put
you away
close it up move it off to the side next
up my friends let's pop this [ __ ] open
whoa this looks like dog dukey if your
dog only eight bones for a whole week
but this right here is there a jackpot
please with dulce de leche apparently I
found out recently through my Mexican
connect also known as Tiffany told me
that horchata
doesn't have a H its order Jaffa she was
upset at me she goes David you don't say
it like that every time I get street
tacos I always get a horchata with it
it's cinnamony it's milky it's ricey
it's delicious it's cool it's refreshing
and it makes my hard stain okay let's
get right into this ooh
this right here cousin is a twist you
know what cuz it's twisted like dead
dulce de leche I believe is like cooked
down condensed milk for what I remember
correct me if I'm wrong chefs out there
I don't think the chef's watching this
they're probably laughing at me well
[ __ ] you too
that's what kind of flavor or just play
with us or just everybody but I'll be
back donut el muy bueno I really wish I
knew Spanish I was like this
I actually do like the texture I'm
pretty sure it's the same batter and
they cook it the same way but maybe it's
the way maybe the way it cooks in this
shape it doesn't allow it to be as soft
and pillowy as this doughnut here
however I will say this it does have the
Ortz at the flavor there's nothing wrong
with this this is good cinnamon sweet
cream should we don't up you got that
caramel topping taste you get from the
dulce de leche
thank you Jesus and for the final
contender in round three - okay that
[ __ ] boys and for the final contender
in round we have donut friend donut
friend is actually my personal favorite
donut shop kind of go here frequently
specifically because my roommate goes
are all the time and I'm not supposed to
eat this [ __ ] but he keeps bringing them
back and eating them in front of my face
you [ __ ] and for the last one we also
have a delicious glass of milk I'm
lactose so this is lactate so no more
poop scoop scoop scoop anyways
let's open up the holy grail of
[ __ ] doughnuts Wow
I picked out some unique ones today
donut friend has a lot of variation in
their doughnuts and they're not afraid
to mix in savory and sweet I like them
they're experimental but not only are
their experimental with their doughnuts
they know what the [ __ ] to do with the
flavors you know what I'm saying
sometimes when people do things they
just do things just to do it and I don't
like it because it doesn't taste good
don't do that with food that goes in my
mouth so for the first doughnut that we
are going to be eating out of the bunch
is this one right here I ordered the
[ __ ] didn't what the [ __ ] is this called
again the dista basil I picked out
because it had a very interesting
ingredient in it which is in the middle
of this doughnut my friends is vegan
cream cheese strawberry jam on top with
a sweet
cream with a balsamic stripy glaze let's
give it a go
prettiest hell zebra stripes is what I
call it yeah it's [ __ ] good it's like
really good like jam sandwich I guess
you would say like peanut butter and jam
no peanut no peanut butter because that
shit's overwhelming as hell but that
vegan cream cheese I don't know what the
[ __ ] in it but it's delicious as
health mmm oh yeah that's sweet
like fruity jam right there
and it adds a little tartness to it
fresh basil and this delicious beauty
right here yeah donut bread man you guys
know what to do with donuts man I
[ __ ] love you guys oh yeah
ah they're not [ __ ] around with you
they know what's up they don't when they
create a donut it's gonna be [ __ ]
good oh and make sure you have it with a
cold glass of milk next up my friends is
their creme brulee
donut Jana what creme brulee is creme
brulee if you've never had creme brulee
before and get in a lot of restaurants
that are fancy I guess I guess it's a
French dish but it's basically um I
don't know what the exact term is but
it's the [ __ ] that you make before you
make like vanilla ice cream you take
that and you bake that [ __ ] and then
after you come out of the oven and a
water bath you're basically put sugar on
top of it and then you Pralay that
[ __ ] with a flame and you make
it nice and crackling from that sugar
and you create this hard caramel hear
that that's that rumored sugar you know
it's funny before this doughnut was
created here a few other places have it
as well I always wanted creme brulee to
be put into a doughnut and a lot of
people started doing it and it made me
very happy because I don't have to make
it my goddamn self as you can see as I
mentioned before brûléed sugar hear that
hear that that's right [ __ ] and inside
you're gonna have that sweet cream in
the middle let's give this a go Oh God
yo
yo like dead toffee candy well they're
perfectly raised donut oh I'd take that
again
yo [ __ ] everything else you heard about
doughnuts if you don't like doughnuts yo
have that creme brulee donut that's very
reminiscent of that crackly top that you
get in a creme brulee and when you get
to the center and you bite into that
cream nothing like it that's probably
one of my favorite doughnuts I've ever
eaten in my life I would [ __ ] you
finally I say this for the last not
because I think it's gonna taste the
best but I've done a friend they have a
very unique unique flavor this is their
Surratt chosen doughnut
what's inside this US we're talking
about coconut bacon strawberry jam and
peanut butter on with a glazed doughnut
and their sriracha sauce is it a little
sriracha no it's not because I smelled
this sriracha right when we open that
box and it smacked me in the face like a
angry mama when she knew you got an F on
your report card specifically a Korean
mom you see that right there they
definitely don't skimp out on those
ingredients that's peanut butter yep
and that right there is that sriracha
sauce I was talking about I'm actually a
little bit worried about this but I'm
not really sure what this is gonna taste
like I don't really know what coconut
bacon is maybe it's like bacon cooked in
coconut fat who knows but before you
guys try it i'ma try it for you so let's
experience this together butterfly in
the sky I can go twice as high it's it
just take a look they stand up book I'm
eating donuts I can't eat everything
hold up [ __ ] spicy as [ __ ]
I don't know how to feel about that
mm-hmm it's not bad because don't offend
always does the foundation right the
donuts are always been their race
doughnut that's always awesome as hell
pillowy is [ __ ] there's a nice bike to
it coconut bacon I think I know what it
is it's not bacon there's no pork in it
but it's like fried pieces of coconut
shavings I literally thought it was
gonna be bacon or maybe it's um
coconut fried and bacon fat I'm trying
to figure this out I don't know what it
is but it's definitely not begging it's
coconut shavings
it's just that spiciness that kind of
throws me off now I'm used to having a
little bit of spice in my food like if
you have chocolate and they put in a
little bit of cayenne pepper in it it
adds like this little background heat
you know I mean sriracha however is very
very forward if you've noticed if you
eat anything with sriracha sriracha
takes over like a mother clucks like an
Asian mom when she cleans a room it's
just it's all it's her room at that
point it's just too heavy it's kind of
like garlic like when you use too much
garlic and it becomes very heavy-handed
all you're really eating is garlic and
in this case that sriracha is very very
powerful and then on top of that two
peanut butter is also a very prevalent
flavor as well so for me it kind of just
like battles in my mouth I'm not sure if
I like it but I will say this if you
like that complexity I guess you would
say if you like really strong flavors
then this is probably gonna be that
doughnut for you I will not say that
this doughnut tastes bad because still
tastes good it just might not be for me
yeah not for me going back to this mmm
there you have it everybody those are
the reviews of three donut places in LA
that you can go to one of them donut
friend is my personal favorite and one
of them I actually didn't get to try it
all and the reason why today I didn't
actually get a lot of the favorite
Donuts that I had there they actually
rotate their flavors a lot so I got
three Donuts that I haven't tried
specifically that creme brulee when I
even know that was on the menu and when
I saw it I got [ __ ] hype so I had to
order it but let me know what you think
what are your favorite donut places in
LA maybe I'll go out and try them maybe
we'll see what's up there's a lot of
food offerings in this city there's no
way I can eat them all but I'm gonna try
see y'all next time [ __ ] oh [ __ ] did
I get on the lens oh [ __ ] I spit that
everywhere